حياكم الله مشاهدينا مستمعينا الكرام في
هذا الجزء الثاني مثل ما وعدناكم بنتابع
الحديث مع الدكتور الباقر عفيف وهو الباحث
السوداني الذي
ركز بحوثها على دراسات الاجتماعيه
والهويه والحكم في السودان وله مؤلفات
تحديدا عن الدارفور والهويه في اقليم
دارفور حياك الله معنا من جديد دكتور الله
يخليك شكرا جزيلا مثل ما وعدنا مستمعينا
ومشاهدينا بنتكلم في هذا الجزء الثاني عن
قوات الجنجويد
وهاتي بدا اليوم مع المشهد السياسي الحالي
في السودان عادت الى الواجهه مره اخرى
وهناك الكثير من الملابسات التي لا زالت
مرتبطه بهذا بهذا الاسم وبهذه القوات
المسلحه
اسمح لي اسالك في البدايه دكتور متى بدا
او متى نشا تجمع
الجنجويد هذا
[موسيقى]
الجنجويد العباره ظهرت في العام 2003
وانطلقت الصاروخ كما وصفتها لتصبح جزء من
المصطلحات التي يتم تداولها في العالم كله
في الواشن في نيويورك
في التسميه في سي ان ان في كذا انا قلت
اعاني العباره
اللي حملت هذه
الامن الظروف حملت هذه العباره لتصبح
لتدخل القاموس
مش في اللغه العربيه وحسب انما القاموس
السياسي العالمي
اصبحت بكل اللبن كلمه جنجويد وهي
ظهرت بالاسم ده هناك يعني تفسيرات متعدده
لماذا تعني واحده من التفسيرات يقولون ان
الجنجويتي اختصار لكلمه جن يركب على جواد
يعني تجسيد للشر المطلق لانها لما جاءت
قوه ظهرت كقوه مدمره
قوه
عمياء لا تتقيد باي قيد انساني مهما كان
لا تتقيد في حربها يعني لا تعرف شيء عن عن
اخلاقيات الحرب ببساطه شديده جدا تمارس
القتل تمارس الحرق تمارس النهب تمارس
الاغتصاب تمارس القتل بابشع ما يكون
ولذلك يعني قوه منفرده
ولذلك
سميت بهذا الاسم
ولكن هي ترمز لايش الشيء المهم ان هي ترمز
لاكبر خطيئه ارتكبت الدوله المركزيه في
السودان
وهي في الحقيقه لم ترتكبها في العام
اشتكبتها منذ بعيد
في حروب
العبثيه الحروب الاهليه الداخليه نحن نعلم
انه منذ ان نشات الدوله في العام 1955
بدا علوم عن السودان وبدا السودانيون
يحصلون على السلطه
بدات الحرب ضد الجنوب
واصلا يعني الدوله لم تراعي لاي تمرد
باعتباره قضيه سياسيه
عشان تعالجي سياسيا وانما
قضيه امنيه قضيه تمرد على الدوله لابد ان
تقمع
ويغضى عليها وعجزت ان تقمع وان تقضي عليها
لمده خمسين عام ده ذاته يورينا ان هذه
الطبقه السياسيه التي كانت تتحكم في امور
لاحظي انا بقول الطبقه السياسيه لانه جاءت
حكومات مدنيه جاءت حكومات عسكريه جاءت
حكومات يمينيه جاءت حكومات يساريه كلها
اتفقت على مواصله الحرب
الطريقه هذه التي واصلتها في يعني 50 عام
ما توقفت قالت ننظر
كيف نقدر نحن البلد فقير نحتمل حرب طويله
الماده زي لماذا يعني
ماذا نريد ان نحقق لم تساله الحسين هذا
السؤال لذلك
هي لما عجز الجيش
ان يحسم
هذه الحركات سميت حركات متمرده
لجا لطريقه كيف يخوض بها حرب رخيصه الثمن
فجاءت حبوب لاكبر خطيئه تتخذها الدوله
السودانيه ان تشوف
قال لي واقعه فيها الحرب
الجيران الاخرين للمجموعات التي
تقود الحرب
فتسلح تلك المجموعات
وتطلقها ضد المجموعات التي الحرب
لان ما عندها مرتبات اليوم لان بس بتديهم
اسلحه وبتقول لهم بعد ده الغنيمه شيلوها
انتم
اذا
تسمح في كان ذكرت مصادر بان
الجنجويد كانت كاسم
ظهر منذ يعني حكم الصادق المهدي في 87 وهو
الذي انشا هذا التجمع هل هذا دقيق كان
يسمى حتى البعض يقول انك يسمى تجمع قريش
لا هو في حقيقه الامر انشا قوات اسمها
المراحيل
المهدي زي ما قلت لك هو قبل الصادق المهدي
كانت الحكومات العسكريه
السابقه
وظفت مجموعات قبليه في جنوب السودان سمتها
القوات الصديقه
نفس الفكره في حرب الوكاله انا قلتها
اسميها المراحل في مرحله
اسميت القوات الصديقه اولا ثم اسميت قوات
المراحيل ثم اسميت الجنجويل لكن الاسماء
متنوعه تشير الى فكره واحده هي فكره حرب
بالوكاله رخيصه الثمن
خوضها مجموعات معينه
ضد المجموعات المتمرده التي في نظر الدوله
متمرده
والحافز المقدم لتلك المجموعات التي
تسلحها الدوله
انها يعني تنهب وتغنم
حروب رخيصه بالوكاله طيب
ايش اسم الجنجويد من
عليها هذا الاسم
اطلقه المجموعات في دارفور التي اصبحت
ضحيه لهذه الجنجويل هي التي اطلقت اسم
الجندويل ايوه طب استاذي كان يعني هناك ما
بين ترجمه هذا المعنى
انا ارتبطت بعده معاني منها جنه على جواد
اذا كان يعني اذا كان كلام يعني كنت دقيقه
في التعبير عنها
وايضا بمعنى
الفارس او الخيل والسلاح وما بين معنى اخر
اصبحت تعني النهب والسرقه والقتل
الى اين اصبح المعنى في القاموس اليوم
لكلمه الجنجويد زي ما ذكرتها انه هي
كلمه الجندويل داله على الانفلات على قوه
لا تتقيد باي قيد في ممارسه الحرب لذلك
لكن انا ذكرت ايضا وده الاهم من الكلمه
نفسها من الناحيه من ناحيه القاموس اللغوي
انه هي
هي تشير فكر الى فكره
الحرب الرخيصه الثمن حرب الوكاله التي
تقوم بها مجموعات سكانيه ضد مجموعات
سكانيه اخرى نيابه عن الدوله
واللي بحكم
التعريف ده يبقى هي اسست الاساس لا اخلاقي
لهذه المجموعات لانك انت لما تدي انسان
سلاح وتقول له امشي اقتل وانهب انت اديته
رخصه
لممارسه
اسوا صور انواع الحروب اللي هي الحروب
الهدف الاساسي هو النهب
فقط
فلذلك انا قلت انه هي جريره التي ارتكبتها
الدوله المركزيه في السودان ان هل هي
ترتبط بالقبائل العربيه فقط ام انها يعني
عندما انشات حكومه نيميري مثلا في اواخر
عهدها حاجه اسمها القوات الصديقه القوات
الصديقه دي هي القوات مؤسسه من اكبر قبيله
ثانيه بعد قبيله الدينكا في الجنوب اللي
هي قبيله النوير
قبيلتين كبار في جنوب السودان متنافسات
عندما اسس الدكتور جون قرن الحركه الشعبيه
لتحرير السودان واصبح هو من قبيله الدنكا
وكبار القاده من قبيله الدنكا
تفتغت ذهنيه
النميري الوقت انه يسلح قبيله افراد من
قبيله النوير المنافسه
ويطلقهن ضد جيران الدينكا عشان يحاربوا
رخيصه
جنوبيين في في من قبيله النوير ضد
جنوبيين اخرين
مؤسسين تاسيس على قبيله الدقه
المهدي برضو بيحارب في الحركه الشعبيه
لتحرير السودان قام اطلق عليهم المجموعات
العربيه المتاخمه لهم
قبيله البجاره
مجموعات عربيه
جند منها ما يعرف بالمراحيل الوقت الذات
واللواء بالمناصر الموجوده الان رئيس حزب
الامه الان اللواء معاش مناصر هو كان وزير
الدفاع في عهد الصادق المهدي وهو الذي
تولى
تسليح القبائل العربيه المتاخمه للقبايل
الجنوبيه بالسلاح وهو الذي اسس قوه ما
يعرف الوقت داق بالمراحيل
واطلقوا ضد ضد
القبايل الجنوبيه المتاخمه لهم وعملوا
ارتكبوا فضائع كبير جدا جدا لعل اكبر ما
يعرف بمذبحه الضعين حيث قتل الاف
الجنوبيين العزل قتلا وحرقا
وبشكل بشع جدا جدا تم التوثيق له بكتاب
مشهور جدا اسمه مجزره الضعين
من الاكاديميين السودانيين المعروفين
انه مثل ما تفضلت انها لا تقتصر على يعني
قبائل معينه او اثنيات معينه او عرق معين
كيف جاء يعني دائما يعني كثير من الاعلام
الغربي والعربي
حتى من التيار الحركه الاسلاميه ما يصف ان
الاحداث التي كانت في دارفور تطهير عرقي
او اباده عرقيه وعنصريه وانها مثلا قبائل
عربيه ضد القبائل الافريقيه لماذا يعني
محاوله او المساعي الى تصوير المشهد في
دارفور بهذا الشكل هل هو غياب فهم دقيق
للاحداث ام انها متقصد لا لا ما متقصد هو
لانه في دارفور كان التسليح للقبائل
العربيه ما انت يعني ما حسب الظرف اللي
وقعت فيه
التمرد في نظر الدوله
يعني ده تمروا لما كانت تمرد هو التمرد في
جنوب السودان احنا نتكلم عن 2003 قضيه هي
الاساس ما انت سالتي سؤال انه كيف لما قلت
لك
لحروب الوكاله ما بالضروره مقتصر فقط على
القبائل العربيه ان هناك دليل قبل كده
وظفت
يبقى لكن لما نجي لدارفور لانه السودان في
حروب كثيره لما نجي الاداره القبائل التي
صلحت هي القبائل العربيه
والقبائل التي نشات منها الجنجويد هي
قبائل العربيه
وهي التي قامت باعمال اباده ضد القبائل
غير العربيه في دارفور
هي التي اختلعت الشعوب الاصليه في دارفور
من 4
وزغاوه
ومساليب وخلاف من بقيه القبائل الصغيره
التي الاصليه الموجوده في دارفور دي
اقتلاعات من ارضهم نحن عندنا
اثنين ونصف مليون نازح في داخل دارفور
واكثر من نصف مليون نازح خارج دارفور دي 3
مليون نازحين فقط كلهم قبائل ما فيهم
قبيله عربيه واحده كلهم من القبايل
الزنجيه او القبايل الافريقيه او القبايل
غير العربيه
الذي حمل السلاح واقتلعوا من جذور هي
القبائل العربيه التي
الجنجويد اللي سلحتهم الحكومه لذلك
التوصيف دقيق لما نجي لدارفور انه فعلا دي
القبائل العربيه التي جندتها الحكومه
واطلقتها ضد القبائل الغير العربيه
فعلت فيها كل الجرائم دي جرائم الحرب
اباده تطهير عرقي كله قام في دارفور وحدث
هل كان لانه يعني اذا تسمح لي معلش يعني
تتفهم بالنسبه لي الموضوع طبعا الموضوع
السوداني
ومتشعب جدا فيعني لو تتحملني شوي الله
يسلمك دكتور هل ان مثلا تسليح قبائل
القبائل العربيه مرتبط مثلا في انك
اللي كانوا اتباع للترابي من قبيله
القبيله افريقيه اصول افريقيه فكان المراد
بان تكون جبهتين متناقضتين يواجه بعضهم لا
هنا امرين في
فيما فعلته الحكومه حكومه البشير
من انها اتت بهذه القبائل العربيه وسلحات
الجنجويد لتخوض بهم حرب رخيصه الثمن لا
تكلف الحكومه شيئا ولكن تكلف دارفور ماسك
كبيره جدا
نجي لصراع الدوله صراع السلطه
القبيله
الانشات
حركه العدل والمساواه ما قبل العربيه
هي قبيله افريقيه مثل ما ذكرت لنا في
الجزء الاول
فهي لا لانه ده ما عنده علاقه
بارض دارفور دي حركه نشات في ظل الصراع
على السلطه في الخرطوم
لذلك يعني عندما اصبح القاده
قاده الحركه والمنتمين كلهم من القبائل
المنتمين للترابي تلاميذه الافريقيه قبيله
الزراون بالتحديد
اصبحت الحركه
مصدره مصدر تغذيته بالمحاربين والمقاتلين
من هذه القبيله وهي قبيله افريقيه
ده في ظل الصراع على السلطه ولكن
مثل ما تكون
هنا ما بين طرفين بيكون
مدافع للاقتتال اكثر لما انها تكون من نفس
القبيله او من نفسه العرق ما تشوف الموضوع
بهذا الاقتتال يمكن ان يكون بين في داخل
القبيله الواحده يمكن ان يكون بين ابناء
يمكن ان يكون البناء على المصالح دوافع
الدفع دوافع المصلحه
الاقتصاديه والمصلحه السياسيه والصراع حول
السلطه يمكن ان يتم بين ان يتم من الاشقاء
صحيح لكن هذا
لا يعني المكسب
س
ريع اذا حاول يعني شخص ما الاستثمار
الفروق اذا استخدمته
لتستخدم
الاختلاف والمنافسه بين القبائل
والعداوات التاريخيه بين القبائل
فحيكون كمان الوقود اكبر ده حصل فيما
يتعلق بتجنيد الحكومه حكومه البشير
للقبائل العربيه واطلاق ضد منافسينها
التقليديين اللي هم القبائل الافريقيه
طب
الجينز
هناك
من اتباع البشير من يرى بان الجنجاويل
خونه وانهم يعني تخلوا وتركوهم وهناك من
التيار الترابي من يراهم لديهم يعني ثائر
مبيت للقتال الذي كان في عام 2003 حضرتك
كيف تشوف اليوم موقف الجنجويد يعني
الابتعاد والقفز من مركب البشير
وفي الحقيقه يعني
[موسيقى]
هناك
مثل سوداني يقول
في القرض تلقاه في جده
هي المعزه
يعني عندما تاكل المعزه نباتات النبات
القرض
يظهر
في شكله تساقط شعرها
في جيلي ده من عن جلدها
والخواجات الانجليزي بالذات الامريكان
عندهم عباره ايضا مثل يقول فيه
تروس
اللي هي في النهايه الانسان يقابل اعمال
يده
وهذا ما حدث بالنسبه
للحكومه البشير
لانهم صنعوا
شيطان نريد
ليقتلوا به اعدائه بعد ان فرغ لهم من
اعدائهم اتجه لهم
اتجه لهم يرسهم
فده ما حدث بالضبط لانه
هذه القوه انشا البشير لحمايته الشخصيه
وزي ما قلت لك لما
الحاكم يصبح هدفه الاكبر هو
التشبث بكرس السلطه مهما كلف من امر حتى
ولو ادى الى اقسام البلد زي ما حدث في
جنوب السودان تخلى عن جنوب السودان لكي
يستمر هو حاكم
وحرق اقليم دارفور لكي يظل هو حاكم
وقتل المزح
وباع الارض
قمه دي كانت قمه ما يمكن
الاستدلال للسلطه يعني بالنسبه للبشير انه
ممكن يهين نفسه
ويدفع من كرامته عشان ما يبقى في السلطه
فاذا انت ما بتهمك كرامتك الشخصيه يبقى ما
بهمك بلدك ما بتهمك ارضك ما بتهمك ممكن ان
تبيع اي شيء يمكن ان تبيع عرضه لكي ما
تتمسك بهذه السلطه وده ما فعله البشير
فجاب السلح
يسلح مجموعته لكي تحميه وكان يسميها حمايه
حمايتي صحيح استاذ اسمح لي
الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه اليوم
ومناصريها بنشوف الدعايه بانها تحرض على
قوات الدعم السريع او قوات الجنجويد في
اطار ارتبط بها في موضوع دارفور
ولكن بنفس الوقت بان يتم التغافل على ان
البشير هو الجنجويدي رقم واحد
فكيف ينسجم هذا الحركه الاسلاميه في
الحقيقه هي الجندويل برقم واحد ايضا مع
البشير وهي التي انشات هذه القوه
لتقمع بها الشعب السوداني كيف في الحركه
الاسلاميه انشات الجنجويد ايضا ما هي
الحركه الاسلاميه عندما انشقت ما اصبحت
الجزء جسم المؤتمر الوطني دين اسلاميين
قاعدين مع البشير والرئيس الحركه
الاسلاميه اللي توفى اللي اسمه الزبير
احمد حسن هو كان موجود مع مؤيد للبشير
وبقي الناس كلهم مؤيدين للبشير وخرج هناك
القسم الاصغر اصبح مع الترابي
فهم كلهم حركه اسلاميه هل البشير عندما
انا انا اعني الحركه الاسلاميه اذا اشرطه
واذا اشرت الى التراب كلهم حركه اسلاميه
صحيح
انشا يعني قمعوا الشعب السوداني قمع رهيب
وعندما انفصلوا عن بعضهم البعض اتفقوا على
قمع الشعب السوداني
لذلك
البشير انشا هذا هو انشؤوها الاسلاميين
الموجودين في الجيش
[موسيقى]
سلحوها من الجيش السوداني ومن دافع
الضريبه السودانيه
والى ان اصبحت قوه هائله قوه موازيه للجيش
ده كله عمل ايدي الاسلاميين الليله اللي
بيحرضونا على ان هذه حرب الجيش ابدا الحرب
الجيش السوداني الجيش السوداني ضحيه هذه
الحرب الحرب دي هي حرب الاسلاميين الاخيره
هي الحرب التي عندما هذه اليد الباطشه
اللي اسمه حميتي وحمايه عندما قرر
الاستقلال
عنهم
قالوا لا اصبح عقبه بينهم وبين الشعب قمع
الشعب السوداني قالوا نخلص منه بسرعه عشان
نتفرغ لقمع الشعب السوداني لذلك الحرب دي
حرب الاسلاميين في الحقيقه هي حرب
الاسلاميين الجيش ورطوا فيها الجيش بشكل
ما مستعده له ولا اختار وكده ولا توقيته
ولا ميدانه
والان بيدفع الجيش ثمنه والشعب السوداني
كله بيدفع الثمنها وهم مهزومين فيها حتى
هذه اللحظه فلذلك
داء عمل يدهم بقابلهم الان وده
اخرى ومن يفعل يعمل مثقال ذره خير يرى ومن
يعمل مثقال ذره شرا يره يره في الحال الان
هم يرون الشرور التي صنعوها بايديهم تتوجه
نحو صدورهم والحرب الان حضرتك
تشوفوا حمدتي بانه
فيما يحدث مؤخرا في السودان انه تحرر من
سطوه الحركه الاسلاميه في السودان وهذا هو
سبب
الاقتتال او
بسبب القتال لو تذكري انه
بعد ما لحد عمل الانقلاب بتاع 25 اكتوبر
2021 كان عمله بالتحالف مع البرهان
واي بالتحالف مع الحركه الاسلاميه هو
الانقلاب بتاع 25 اكتوبر
وانقلاب الحركه الاسلاميه لكن
البرهان اقنع حميتي بانه لا انا وانت نعمل
الانقلاب مع بعض ضد المدنيين لكن عندما
استفاق اليوم التالي حميدي اكتشف انه في
حقيقه هو كان مستغل وانه هو نفذ انقلاب
للحركه الاسلاميه بدليل انه اول القرارات
التي اتخذها البرهان بعد الانقلاب انه
اعاد للحركه الاسلاميه كل الممتلكات التي
نهبتها من الشعب السوداني واستردتها عنهم
حكومه حمدوق
ارجع عليهم جميع الممتلكات وارجع جميع
الوظائف التي لم يستحقها وفصلوهم ايام
حكومه حمدوق ارجعهم لمواقعهم وكاننا ما
عملنا اي ثوره في السودان فاول ما ادرك ده
هو قال انه داء في الحقيقه انقلاب
الاسلاميين وانا
اشتركت في الانقلاب وده كان خطا اول ما
اذان الانقلاب وقال انه الانقلاب خطا ده
التمرد طوالي الحركه الاسلاميه
اعتبرتهم متمرد لابد اما ان يرجع الى بيت
الطاعه او نشيله من امامنا
فلما
اصبح في وساطات دوليه
الوساطات محليه
لكي ما يلتقوا البرهان مع حميتي يتفادى
الحرب يوم 15 ابريل
الحركه الاسلاميه
ذهبت وهاجمت
مقرات الدعم السريع واطلقت الرصاص الاولى
وورطت الجيش
في الحرب بدليل انه كبار قاده الجيش ما
كانوا يعلموا ان هنالك حرب
المفتشه العامه اللي بيتخذ قرار الحرب
مدير معهد الاستخبارات وكبياء كبار
الجنرالات لم يعلموا بخبر الحرب الا بعد
ان اشتعلت
عشان كذا امسكوهم كلهم معتقلين عند الدعم
السريع فدي دي حرب الحركه الاسلاميه ضد
الاداء حقت الباطشه اللي خرجت عن سيطرتها
وعايزه تزيل لانه انهم يدركون انه ما دام
هناك هذه القوه المسلحه يبقى ما بيستطيعوا
يستفردوا بالشعب السوداني
فلابد ان تزال هذه القوه المسلحه حتى
يستطيعوا ان يستفردوا بالشعب السوداني
ويستعيدوا سلطتهم مجددا بعد ان
ذهبت بها ثوره ديسم قراءه دكتور جدا مهمه
وتحليل يستحق يعني لا يعني التامل فيه
واسمح لي ابغى ارجع شوي لموضوع طبعا هو
مرتبط فيه ايضا بالموضوع الجنجويد الى
قضيه دارفورد طبعا احنا نعرف انه تم تحديد
من قبل المجتمع الدولي اطار المسؤوليه على
البشير ووزير الدفاع واحمد البرهان اللي
كان
الحاكم او الوالي في ولايه ديرفور في ذلك
الوقت ومطلوبين هم لمثول امام المحكمه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والترابي بعد بان خرج من السجن طالب
البشير بان يذهب ويسلم نفسه للمحكمه
الدوليه
لكن من خلال حديثك دكتور لماذا كان هو
البشير ورجالات المقربين من كانوا ضمن
المسائله من قبل الجنائيه الدوليه وتم
اغفال دور الترابي ودور
الحركه حركه العدوى المساواه المسلحه في
ذلك الوقت فيما حدث من جرائم في داخل
اقليمي ديرفور
لانه طبعا دي كانت الحكومه يعني المحكمه
الجنائات الدوليه بتحمل المسؤوليه جميع
لكن المسؤوليه الكبرى هي مسؤوليات الحكومه
لانه البشير والذي امر بهذه الحرب الحرب
الاباده
الكبار زي احمد هارون هم نفذوا هذه الحرب
لذلك اصبحوا هم مطالبين بواسطه
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
هناك بعض اصحاب الحركات المسلحه ايضا
اتهموا مثلوا امام محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
لكن لم يجد عليهم من ادله كافيه لكي
يحاكموا
هو هو السبب يعني تحديدا لكن لانه
الذين امروا بهذه الحرب والذين نفذوا
الحرب
وتوفرت ادله كافيه
بتوجيها الاتهام لهم وجهت لهم الاتهامات
لكن مثل ما تفضل دكتور انها كانت يعني
بالاساس حركه العدوى المساواه انها نشات
من خلال بعد المفاصل التي وقعت في داخل
الحركه الاسلاميه بين الجناحين البشير
والترابي وان بدات يعني نشاطها الامني في
العام 2003 بمهاجمه القوات
قوات البشير او القوات الجيش السوداني في
ذلك الوقت محميات او مواقع عسكريه للجيش
فما نقدر يعني هل ممكن وصف ان الموضوع
متبادل ما بين الطرفين يعني حتى الحركه
الاسلاميه هي بدات في مثل هذا محاوله
انقلاب على النظام على حكم البشير
نعم
الجناح الترابي حاول محاولات عديده ان
في ظل صراعه على السلطه مع البشير
الانقلاب عليه وزي ما ذكرت لك يعني هي
حركه العدل
اشتغلت في اقليم دارفور على اعتبار اضعاف
الحكومه
واجبارها على ان يعني
تتنازل لهم عن على الاقل قسم من السلطه
ولكن ظلت
الحرب دائره حركه العدل والمساواه استطاع
البشير ان
يهزمه عسكريا في الحقيقه هزمها
حميته هو اللي استطاع الذي في الحقيقه
هزيمه هزم حركه العدل والمساواه هزيمه
النكراء في معركه مشهوره جدا اسمها معركه
جوز دانجو وهذه المعركه فيها اباده حركه
العدل والمساواه في الحقيقه هو حماتي كان
يعني هو حماتي كان هو القائد لهذه المعركه
كان هو القائد في الحقيقه
البشير للقضاء على حركات دارفور كلها
واستطاع ان ينتصر عليها كلها ويخرجها من
دارفور نهائيا انت عارفه انه يعني
منذ ذلك الوقت
البشير عن طريق حميدتي استطاع ان يهزم
التمرد عسكريا واخرج حركه العدل والمساواه
واخرج حركه تحرير السودان بقياده مني من
دارفور لم يكن عندها اي وجود في دارفور
بقوا يمشي شغالين مرتزقه في ليبيا كانوا
بيحاربوا مع مع حفتر
في ليبيا واصبح ما عندهم اي هدوء في داخل
السودان وهو استطاع ان يقضي عليهم حميتي
الاستطاع ان يهزموني
طب دكتور اسمح لي باخر سؤال اليوم على
حركه العدوى المساواه هل لديها قوات مسلحه
او ميليشيا مسلحه عندهم ميليشيا مسلحه
كانت مرتزقه في دارفور اقصد في ليبيا
تحارب
وبعد بعد ذلك اتى بقاياها رجع للسودان بعد
الاتفاقيه جوبا
وكان تعداد قليله جدا لذلك حركه العدل
والمساواه مع حركه تحرير السودان بقياده
مني
بدو يجندوا لحركه بعد ان جاءوا بعد
اتفاقيه 2021
حتى بدو يجندوا
لتجنيد جديد لقواتهم
عشان يكون يبدو عندهم جيش كبير لكن هم في
الحقيقه ما كان عندهم شيء بقى قواتهم لسه
قاعده بتحارب في ليبيا مع مع
الحركات الاسلاميه ومع عمليه يدفع اكثر
عباره عن مرتزقه
فيها دكتور واسمح لي اني اختم هنا حديثنا
تبقى قضيه دارفور ازمه ماثله وماضيه ولكن
يبقى السؤال هل الحشد اليوم في اقليم
دارفور هو انعكاس لاحداث الماضي وبذات
المعطيات ام ان السنين بدلت من خارطه
التحالفات وتقاطع الرهانات هذا جماعات
وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]